[Musique]
emilie gens car bonjour vous avez 65 ans
bonjour mais la maison car bonjour
monsieur livory bonjour les auditeurs de
la martinique et plus particulièrement
le vauclin qui m'est chère ainsi que les
quartiers du voc là alors je poursuis
votre présentation vous aident-ils 65
ans vous êtes responsable de service à
la cnam caisse nationale de l'assurance
maladie vous ichi déjà présenté vous
étiez déjà présenté en 2014
je me souviens bien mais la liste avait
capoté n'aviez pas été jusqu'au bout
voilà il vous y étiez candidate
également aux législatives de 2010 est
vous allez mener la liste donc en 2020
vauquelin solidaire et partage une liste
soutenue par l'association démocratie
citoyenne qu'est ce qui vous motive
madame gens car alors quand je regarde
ce qui se passe au niveau international
national et local
je constate qu'il ya une un climat
anxiogène
alors je me dis là d'opposition soit je
reste spectateur
j'attends que ça se passe je râle je
vois là je me les amants je me roule par
terre ou alors je suis actrice je me
lève et je suis une citoyenne engagée et
et
j'ai décidé de continuer à me mettre au
service de la société au service du
collectif de mettre mes compétences au
service de tout le monde et est donc
plus particulièrement évoqué puisque
nous sommes aux municipales de 2020 afin
de répondre à leurs besoins
quels sont les besoins de vos clients à
vivre ensemble travailler pour notre
bien-être mettre en place la démocratie
participative et quelquefois bizarrement
subvenir aux besoins primaires de
quelques personnes de la société et
notre pays
notre projet est innovant on propose au
voc linois donc on va revenir sur on va
revenir sur le projet mais madame donc à
ce que la mise aventures de 2014 ne va
pas se reproduire
on va juste expliqué
j'avais une commune sans incriminer qui
que ce soit je vais juste dix colistiers
j'avais des causes est tombé j'avais 39
voilà et quand une première personne m'a
dit non 12e je me suis dit bon c'est pas
grave j'en ai 39
et puis après je me suis rendu compte
que finalement ma liste a fondu comme
neige au soleil et que ont tombé pendant
la période du carnaval et je n'ai pas eu
le temps de me retourner pour présenter
une liste
monsieur paragraphe je me suis relevé et
je repart de plus belle et je fais
autrement est là et on va jusqu'au bout
et lavier jusqu'au bout c'est sûr tout à
fait voilà d'accord vous restez donc de
le credo de l'engagement citoyen moyen
est ce que ces modes c'est pas une mode
c'est être citoyen c'est un statut
c'est un statut qui rassemble les gens
autour du respect autour de certaines
valeurs comme le respect le travail que
pour le collectif foule pour la société
avec nos différences mais donc tant
qu'il y aura des hommes
l'idée de la citoyenneté va continuer à
faire son chemin alors comment ça se
traduit dans votre composition de liste
par exemple alors très bien donc
nous passons actuellement avec notre
projet nous déroulons notre projet dans
les quartiers les personnes
après si nous devons voilà en général
ils ont beaucoup apprécié et ils nous
donnent aussi leurs idées et je fais un
appel à volontariat ça c'est innovant
plutôt que d'aller rechercher les gens
que je connais mes amis ma famille pour
construire une liste parce que vous avez
quelques fois c'est plus difficile de
manager les gens qu'on connaît que les
gens qu'on ne connaît pas et c'est une
liste pour aller travailler donc je n'ai
pas vraiment besoin d'avoir d'infinité
j'ai besoin d'avoir des compétences des
personnes qui ont envie de se lever de
travail et donc je fais appel au
volontariat alors nous reste une minute
que quelles sont les grandes nuits mais
leur monde eurojet groupe
mon projet c'est un projet en cinq axes
la cohésion sociale la modernisation la
solidarité le partage la démocratie
citoyenne et l'inclusion sociale et
numérique qui se basent qui s'appuie sur
trois piliers forts
les élus nous avec notre manière de
travailler la transparence là on
n'acceptera d'être évalués également par
la population on ira interroger la
population les élus je disais le 2e
pilier
les agents qui travaillent tout qui
travaille déjà à la mairie qui ont déjà
les compétences aux données personnelles
aux personnels ils nient je le redis il
n'y aura pas de licenciements il y aura
pas de licenciement parce qu'on aura du
travail vu l'ampleur de la tâche
il y aura du travail pour tout le monde
et le troisième pilier la population
qu'on va associer dans les comités de
quartiers dans les comités de pilotage
dans les conseil citoyen pour travailler
ensemble pour le vauclin en moins de 20
secondes
l'attractivité de la commune il faut
travailler sur notre habitude de l'info
de travailler sur l'attractivité de la
commune pour faire oublier la distance
entre le vauclin et les autres communes
pour que les gens aient envie de venir
et de revenir au vauclin c'est vraiment
notre leitmotiv emilie gion car je vous
remercie
je vous remercie au revoir